the next speaker is gagan agal from
Google who will talk about Market
algorithms for auto
[Music]
bidding hi everyone my name is gagan
Agarwal I co-lead the market algorithms
research team at Google uh today I'll be
talking about Market algorithms for auto
bidding this is Joint work with Ashwin
Aran Andres Ariel Jun and mink who are
all colleagues at Google except for
junor who is a student at
Stanford so this is a brief outline of
my talk I'll start by introducing uto
bidding and then I'll talk about a few
research new research questions that
have Arisen in the context of AO
biding so you all probably uh so we'll
start with you know what is auto biding
so to do that we'll first start with
just the basic introduction to auctions
uh that are used for setting online
advertising so you're probably familiar
with the um ads that are shown on the
Google search page when you search for
something like running shoes um Google
will show you some ads um for that and
these ads are selected using an auction
um so whenever a query comes in we
retrieve all the ads which are relevant
to the query and then uh we use an
auction to decide which ads to show and
how much to price uh them for
um right and the U common auction which
is used for selling a single item is the
second price auction or the victory
auction in which the item is given to
the highest bidder for a price equal to
the second highest
bid so from an advertisers perspective
from a buyer perspective they're not
really participating in just one auction
they're typically bidding for a keyword
and they're submitting a per click bid
for the keyword and all the queries that
come in that are that are relevant for
the keyword they participate in all of
those auctions using the bid for this
keyword and what they get in the end is
a total number of Impressions clicks
conversions costs so like these are the
things which are relevant to them so
recently advertisers have been
increasingly using this notion of auto
bidding where instead of bidding
directly into the auctions instead of
directly submitting pery per keyword
bids they give their goals and their
constraints to an auto bidding system
which converts them to bids on their
behalf and the auto bidder uh will take
in these goals and constraints and try
and optimize the objective function
subject to the constraints that the
advertiser has has specified and some
examples of these could be that you're
trying to maximize your click subject to
budget constraint or you're trying to
maximize conversion subject to average
cost per conversion constraints and so
on or you can have multiple of these
constraints um and this is increasingly
being used in the advertising industry
and most of the major advertising
platforms offer some form of auto
bidding now um and here are some
examples from
Google so autoing has given rise to
several new research directions and I'll
talk about some of them in this talk um
so many of these questions are of course
still open and they are an active area
of Investigation so I just like touch on
the new things that we are we are
thinking about these days so the first
problem I'll talk about is algorithms
for auto
bidding so the problem here is as
follows so we have U so so we are now
looking at the point of view of the auto
bidding system it has received some
goals and constraints and it wants to
maximize the objective function subject
to the constraint so it essentially has
multiple items that it can buy for for
to begin with we assume that that these
items have a fixed price we already know
the price and the item I has a price of
Pi in addition um we'll assume there's a
budget constraint and what's called a
tcpa constraint which is an average cost
per conversion constraint we'll
generalize we can generalize this to
other constraints as well but that's
what we'll talk about here so this
problem can be represented as an integer
program and I have shown the IP the lp
relaxation on the right uh and we can
solve this LP and that will give us
that'll solve the item selection problem
for us we know which items to take right
but the solution is not super useful
because it gives me for every item I
need to remember do I want to take it or
not that's like a lot of stuff to
remember when I'm actually trying to
implement it it's not very usable in
practice so to get a more usable
solution we use the duel and um we solve
the duel and we can show that if um so
here like I have these two constraints
that Alpha and beta be the Dual
variables corresponding to them then if
Alpha star and beta star are the optimal
dual variables then the items that you
want to take sorry are over here like
it's represented by this
condition this just follows from um you
know simple Duality
Theory so now this algorithm actually
starts looking useful in practice
because I have I can solve the Dual on a
sample on a representative
representative sample of my data and get
the alpha star and beta star from there
and then I can use it to decide which
items to take in the future and this
extends to more General linear
constraints and objective functions as
well say that
again so they are supposed to be zero
and one but when I saw the lp it is a
fractional solution what we can show is
that since if there only two constraint
it depends on the number of constraints
but the number of fractional XIs you'll
get is bounded like in this case it'll
be two and in practice we'll just ignore
that like you can take them like if XI
is fractional just take it set it to one
you might violate your constraints by
like the cost of one item and typically
in practice the cost of one item is
really small and nobody really cares
about that so um so that's like
the so in to model it you have to say
that you'll be willing to violate your
constraints by a little
bit okay so just to connect this to the
auction right so far we said that the
item prices were fixed but what if the
item prices are coming from an auction
let's say that the seller was was using
a second price auction to sell each item
um in that case the price of an item is
the uh second highest the next is the
price of an item is the highest B bid
among all the other biders so I'm a
fixed bidder it's the it's the highest B
bid among all the other biders in that
case uh we can just bid this amount
basically we just wanted to take
everything whose price was was lower
than this amount uh so if we just bid
this amount we because it's a second
price auction we'll get exactly the
right items so it really fits very well
into the second price Paradigm um
unfortunately if the auction is not
truthful this doesn't work as well um in
fact the optimal bidding algorithm for
non ful auctions can be fairly complex
um so the next thing we'll talk about is
what happens when the we are not just
looking at the perspective of one bidder
keeping all the other bids fixed but all
the biders are in fact using Auto biders
so everybody is using an auto bidder and
the bids can change right so that's our
next question and clearly the bid of the
optimal bid for a bidder depends on the
prices that they are seeing and the
prices that they see depends on the bids
of the other biders so they keep
responding to each other's bids till
they reach an equilibrium and um and
then the question is um you know what
properties of this equilibrium can be
proved so what we can show is that um
the equilibrium exists under certain
conditions U basically some kind of
continuity conditions the items being
small and things like that uh um and it
is ppad hard to
compute then we look at this question of
how good is the equilibrium in terms of
the welfare or the efficiency of the
equilibrium um that is uh is the welfare
at equilibrium how does it compare to
the best possible welfare when the
agents are not even strategic say and
you could make them do whatever they
want to do instead of them behaving
strategically U this is called the price
of Anarchy um in this setting even the
definition of of efficiency is
interesting because biders have cost
constraints so you can't just take their
value as such to compute the efficiency
but you can define a reasonable notion
of efficiency and for that you can show
that the price of Anarchy is two if the
underlying auction that you're using is
vcg um and there are other papers which
figure out the price of Anarchy or bound
the price of Anarchy when the underlying
auction is something
else so I'm not going to go into details
of this result so I'll talk about um the
question of auction design in the
presence of auto
bidding um so in order to talk about
auction design I need to talk about how
the biders are behaving how the buyers
are behaving what are they trying to
achieve so the standard model uh for
bidder behavior in economics is the
Quasi linear utility module where the
buyers are trying to maximize their
values minus their cost right so that's
one model we'll consider second model
we'll consider which is inspired by the
goals and constraints in the auto
bidding systems is the so-called value
maximizing model where the bidder is
literally trying to maximize the
objective that they set subject to the
constraints that they set that's that's
what they're trying to maximize right
and just because of bidder is using Auto
bitting doesn't mean that they have the
second object they have the second
utility function but it's an it's a
utility function that is plausible in
this setting um they could have CI
utility they could have value maximizing
utility they could have some other
utility so if we had quasy linear buyers
who are using auto bidding just as a
system because it gives them some value
and they're going to keep adjusting the
inputs to the system to match their
quasi linear utility function then most
of the results from the Quasi linear
utility model uh carry over uh to the
setting with auto bidding as long as the
Auto biders are behaving optimally but
that's not the case when the biders are
actually value maximizing biders the
utility function is value
maximizing um and there is an emerging
area of research with lots of ongoing
work where um the goal is to develop a
theory of um auction design um under uh
value maximizing
buyers so questions will be like can we
design auctions with better welfare and
revenue um what happens when we change
Reserve prices how do we optimize for
Reserve prices and there is this setting
the multi Channel setting which I'll
talk about in a second which is also
interesting in this
case so I'll talk about two of these
things so I'll talk about Reserve prices
and I'll talk about auction design
hopefully quickly um so we first talk
about the effect of Reserve prices and
how it Compares how it's different
between Quil linear buyers and value
maximizing buyers so let's assume that
the seller is using a second price
auction a truthful auction for every
item um now in the case of quy linear
buyers it's well known that the if you
change Reserve prices uh as long as your
auction is truthful you are the the
buyer is not going to change their bid
their they have their dominant strategy
is to just bid their value but that's
not the case for Value maximizing biders
because it's not um it's not in they
will basically want to shade their bids
so and and they will they will want to
shade their bids differently depending
on the reserve prices so the so the out
the bids change and the outcome changes
as we are changing the reserve prices
and it makes it um hard to optimize for
Reserve
prices um another interesting
observation is that for quasi linear
biders a reserve price of zero always
maximizes welfare but that's because
you're basically charging zero so you're
giving every item to the person who
values it the most and no item is going
unallocated but for the case of value
maximizing biders it's actually not the
case sometimes you can increase Welfare
by raising the reserve price because you
essentially in the case of value
maximizing b sometimes you can afford
items that are above your value because
you got kind of slack on the items which
were cheap for you um so so you can use
that slack on very on expensive items
which are actually above your value but
by raising the reserve price we reduce
the slack uh that a buyer can get
thereby not allowing them to buy items
which were too expenses which which were
much more than their value so that can
actually increase so it's not like all
the time this happens but it can happen
that increasing Reserve prices can
increase increase welfare in this
case
um so next um I will talk about the
multi- channel setting for auction
design so this setting is uh uniquely
interesting in the uh in the case of
value maximizing biders um uh here we
have independent channels or platforms
which own the different items in this
case the different queries that we are
selling or some other items right so
think of these channels as uh different
advertising uh platforms that the
advertiser could have participated on so
they could have pass on Google on
Facebook on newspapers and magazines
right so they could have used all these
advertising channels and The Advertiser
is is optimizing across all of these
channels right so in the case of Quasi
linear biders if I am a channel and I'm
trying to optimize my own auction I
don't need to worry about all the other
channels what happens on the other
channels does not affect their bid on my
channel but in the case of value
maximizing biders who are optimizing
across channels that's not the case
anymore what happens on the other
channels the bid Landscapes on the other
channels have a large impact on the bid
on my channel so so when I change my
auction I change my reserve price it
affects the um optimality of the auction
and the reserve prices on the other
channels as well um so one can think of
this game that the channels are playing
I set my auction I set my reserve price
and um and the then the other channnel
changes their auction the reserve price
and ultimately we reach an equilibrium
of which auction we are using of what
Reserve prices we are using so we
studied uh two problems like we studied
two of these games we studyed the game
where they're setting Reserve prices and
we also study the game where the
channels are trying to choose between a
first price auction or a second price
auction and deciding which auction to go
with interestingly when I am the only
Channel I'm there's only one channel and
the biders are using scale values as
their BDS which is not optimal but is
the simplest strategy to use and
potentially being used in practice
because it's hard to do anything else um
if I'm the only channel in with this
kind of bidding then it's actually
optimal to use the first price auction
with value maximizing biders but with uh
with multiple channels one can actually
construct situations some valuation
functions where U it is actually the
dominant strategy for a a Chann to use
the second price auction independent of
what other channels are doing so the
behavior really changes whether you are
a single channel uh in which case you
might want to use the first price
auction all the time um or there are
multiple channels competing with each
other in which case um you might use
something different depending on the
valuation
functions um sorry I think I said all
this um so I'm going to
skip um okay so in in conclusion there
are lots of new fundamental questions
that arise due to Auto biding and we
talked about some of those there are
many open questions uh that are still
being actively worked on uh including
auction design and um and the
understanding of the multi Channel
setting thank
[Applause]
you is there a quick question for Gan
before we break for
lunch yes
[Music]
cooperate yeah they can biders can
always collude and potentially gain as
much as as if they were a single
B so in practical setup do you also see
auto bidding and the old traditional
coming together and how do you like what
does that create so in practice yeah
these Auto bid are participating in the
same auctions that were originally being
run so there are manual biders as well
as Auto biders in the same auctions so
the good thing was like as we saw in the
auto bidding algorithm right it just
participates in the auction very
naturally uh and they just the auction
is the place where they get combined
together um
yeah all right well let's break for
lunch and we will convene back here at
two o'clock thank you again
God